[Musique]
fin du port du masque et du pass
vaccinale comment la levée des
restrictions sanitaires impact tel les
salles de spectacle et cinéma la
fréquentation des établissements
culturels yves binois semble rebooster
si le public conserve pour l'heure
certaines habitudes il est au rendez
vous à moins d'un mois du premier tour
des présidentielles nous continuons
notre tour d'horizon des professionnels
libinois objectif connaître leurs
attentes pour les élections focus cette
fois ci sur les acteurs culturels avec
un directeur de théâtre et puis les
influences du département sont allés à
la rencontre d'agriculteurs yvelinois
objectif mettre en avant la production
locale en proposant une dégustation dans
un collège des essarts le roi la team 78
cuisiner un menu entrée plat dessert à
base de lentilles pour 40 couverts
[Musique]
mais avant de débuter ce journal un
point sur l'épidémie de kovy de 19 qui
repart à la hausse dans le département
des yvelines selon les chiffres publiés
par le gouvernement le nombre de
nouveaux cas positifs par jour augmente
le taux de positivité est en hausse de
20% en une semaine le taux d'incidence
lui a augmenté de près de 35% sur sept
jours un impact qui ne se ressent pas
sur le nombre d'hospitalisations et de
réanimation globalement en baisse malgré
14 nouvelles hospitalisations
quotidienne
[Musique]
entre 20 et 25% de baisse par rapport à
2010 neuf en ce début d'année 2022 la
fréquentation des salles de spectacles
et de cinéma est encore fragile dans les
yvelines la levée successifs des
restrictions n'effraie pas les
spectateurs au théâtre qu'au lieu de
plaisir les dernières représentations se
sont joués à guichets fermés soit 900
places c'est plutôt un soulagement de
toute façon depuis les annonces qui
concernait le 28 février
sa rebooster totalement la fréquentation
des théâtres et les ventes donc on
retrouve presque un niveau normal de
fréquentation quelques on l'a vu il ya
deux trois ans dans un ancien entrepôt
vide donc on est plutôt très très
heureux je pense pas du tout que et
qu'il y ait la moindre inquiétude de la
part du public du côté de la scène
nationale aussi pas d'annulation du
public qui répond présent si peu de
représentations ont eu lieu depuis la
levée des restrictions la direction note
que le masque est plus une question
d'habitude elle a beaucoup qui ont
conservé le mas lors des représentations
de la semaine dernière ce qui au vu du
nombre de contaminations qui permet
encore assez important me semble assez
assez logique et assez normal voilà mais
il y en a qui en ont profité aussi pour
tout d'un coup respirer mais je pense
que ses habitudes vont cesser petit à
petit depuis ce lundi 14 mars le
contrôle du pass vaccinale n'est plus en
vigueur les saisons culturelles pour les
salles de spectacles prennent fin entre
mai et juin
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle lionel nassetta
j'ai 55 ans et je suis depuis sept ans
le directeur de la scène nationale de
saint quentin en yvelines pendant la
crise sanitaire qui l'attendent à une
activité à l'intérieur du théâtre
puisqu'on a eu si on prend juste l'année
2021 il y aura lui quatre mois de
répétition des kids artistique sur scène
mais on a pu organiser et nous adapter
pour organiser en nombre incroyable
spectacle hors les murs pour maintenir
des projets avec une multitude de
partenaires pour assurer une présence
des artistes sur le terrain dans les
ehpad dans l'est dans les hôpitaux dans
le onze zones rurales en milieu scolaire
je pourrais d'entrée demandé plus de
moyens
plus de moyens pour faire notre travail
je pense que aujourd'hui la question
n'est pas celle là c'est que la question
de la culture et de l'art entre dans le
discours dans le discours politique en
dehors même des questions économiques l
art et la culture c'est notre ouverture
vers l'imaginaire et si on ferme cette
fenêtre vers l'imaginaire la vie
deviendra rapidement un enfer également
un discours que j'entends assez peu sur
la complémentarité entre le numérique et
puis les arts vivants comment est ce que
la culture et l'art chez soi tel qu'il a
pu se développer ces dernières années
peut être totalement complémentaires
delà de la culture et de l'art dans des
lieux de spectacle
[Musique]
à moins d'un mois du premier tour des
élections présidentielles les différents
partis accélèrent leur campagne samedi
12 mars les militants du mouvement
l'union populaire de jean luc mélenchon
se sont mobilisés sur le terrain au
programme à plaisir tractage et porte à
porte willy à des échanges sur ce qui
les révoltes en ce moment et comment
nous collectivement on peut améliorer
leur quotidien pour ça que c'est pas
vraiment un département qui a très ancré
à gauche c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire mais mais ça se passe plutôt bien
pour l'instant c'est à dire que on est
bien accueilli surtout dans les
quartiers populaires là où on va faire
la plupart de nos actions militantes
l'occasion de répondre aux
préoccupations des français sur des
sujets d'actualité avec des points
phares du programme augmenter le smic
tout le monde est pour la retraite à 60
ans tout le monde et pour rétablir lisf
tout le monde et pour arrêter le
glyphosate tout le monde et peut enfin
ainsi de suite quoi comprend les grands
tous les grands éléments du programme la
location de 1000 centres euros pour les
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose qui moi m'intéresse
pas mal le sujet de l'écologie aussi
parce que c'est un sujet qui est
complètement oubliée dans la campagne
jusqu'ici du côté du parti reconquête
d'eric zemmour les militants sont aussi
au rendez vous dimanche 13 mars c'était
l'opération les 48 heures de la
reconquête partout en france et même
dans le petit village yvelinois
darsonville les buts des 48 heures de la
reconquête c'était d'aller au contact
des concitoyens notamment dans ce
village où il ya un fort taux
d'abstention de connaître quels étaient
leurs préoccupations pourquoi il n'avait
pas été aussi voter on a remarqué que
vous on était désespérés par la
politique ils ne savaient pas trop pour
qui voter un temps des changes
directement au contact des citoyens pour
revenir sur les mesures du programme de
leur candidat la préservation de la
culture française qui voulu par eric
zemmour notamment avec la préservation
de la culture française et des
traditions françaises judéo-chrétienne
la protection des os mobiles des
automobilistes pardon avec la
suppression du permis à points d'accord
la protection de la ruralité avec la
prime des 10000 euros qui sera donnée
aux parents qui souhaitent avoir un
enfant au sein de la rivalité est aussi
la préservation des petits points
commerce de proximité qui sont vraiment
le coeur de nos villages la campagne
s'intensifie pour les militants ils
resteront mobilisés jusqu'au dernier
jour de la campagne 8 avril avant le
premier tour prévu deux jours après
[Musique]
florence parly ministre des armées s'est
rendu à saint cyr l'école ce mardi 15
mars au programme une visite de
l'entreprise pro engins l'entreprise est
spécialisée dans la détection des
produits utilisés dans la guerre
chimique un déplacement dont le cadre du
plan d'action pme il vise à soutenir les
entreprises du territoire qui travaille
avec le ministère des armées en 2000
21,6 millions d'euros ont été investis
dans l'entreprise prochain pour financer
leurs systèmes de détection
[Musique]
elle a ouvert ses portes depuis
septembre 2020 wheel of môme est une
école montessori international et
éco-responsable situé à versailles
quatorze enfants sont accueillis durant
la semaine un établissement créé par
deux femmes dont irina l'auvergnat j'ai
envie de plier une attelle et cole qui à
mon avis n'existe pas parce que en plus
de montessori j'amène ma propre culture
j'amène mes propres
penser j'ai voulu à
chercher les éducateurs qui convient à
mes
on est des présentations d'un adulte
auprès des enfants cette école ouverte
tous les jours du lundi au vendredi
s'inscrit dans le cadre de la méthode
montessori sept personnes sont engagées
dans ce projet entrepreneurial
l'association suzanne michaud a
accompagné cette société dans sa phase
de création de bénévoles de
l'association annie show l'ont aidé à
apprendre en main la partie financière
et essayer de structurer son projet
l'association pour favoriser la création
d'entreprises dans les yvelines a
complété l'accompagnement avec un prêt
d'honneur de 50000 euros objectif aider
au démarrage des travaux de l'école
s'ils sont motivés si elles ont la
volonté l'énergie pour mener à bien ce
projet et enfin c'est l'eau si elle
maîtrise les disciplines que doit
posséder un bon entrepreneur du côté de
l'école montessori we love môme une
classe élémentaire pour les élèves de 6
à 12 ans doit ouvrir ses portes en
septembre 2022
[Musique]
les 9 heures ce mercredi 9 mars la team
78 s'est donné rendez vous dans cette
exploitation yvelinoise pour une journée
du champ à l'assiette organisé avec le
département objectif pour les
producteurs locaux faire découvrir leurs
produits aux influences euse relais du
département mais que c'était pour la fin
pas de notre aventure dans la production
de grandes cultures à destination du
local des yvelines et tout
particulièrement des collèges est divine
c'est un
aussi beau que c'est très bien de
multiplier des axes de communication
puis c'est chouette d'avoir un peu
finalement le l'envers du décor de tous
contador dans l'assiette il nous a
expliqué tous qui plantait différemment
même des choses donc voilà on
n'imaginerait pas que ça puisse pousser
dans les yvelines au programme de la
journée cuisine et ses produits locaux
direction le collège les volières aux
essarts-le-roi pour mettre la main à la
pâte mais avant cela il faut s'équiper
l'équipement la charlotte qui va bien et
on va avoir une petite toque à notre nom
et justement c'est intéressant c'est de
voir comment on peut intégrer des choses
local bas à des grosses quantités de
cantine c'est là aussi où finalement il
y en a peut-être plus besoin parce que
c'est nos enfances et voilà c'est eux
qui aussi ont besoin le plus de bien
manger la team 78 est répartie en
plusieurs binômes un travail d équipe
pour décliner la lentille sous toutes
ses formes
elle a commencé notre côté moi je fais
un peu lassé zone euro je commence ma
raisonnement et puis comme ça après on
va faire ça à toutes les deux bon voilà
on va faire une bonne petite entrée
concert verra dans des verrines faire
déjà toutes ses couleurs et malgré le
mal que j'ai toutes les senteurs et le
pape et hissant au menu ce tabou les
deux pattes vers l'est avec l'entier de
corail les lentilles vertes avec filet
de saumon et en dessert des cupcakes
pomme chocolat à base de farine de
lentilles et on en en train de dresser
les cas grec est donc dans les
préparations chocolat
sucré aux pommes caramélisées que des
choses délicieuses quoi et le cas
devient aussi hélas apprendre à faire
cuire et il a fort à faire avec les
coaches à gong la décoration sur le
dessus un avant-goût de légumes quoi
c'est vraiment ça va ça donne un superbe
ou au dessert même dans le sucré et
c'est génial de le savoir parce qu'on a
forcément le réflexe normal de prendre
la farine de blé est classique et là ça
change c'est un très bon goût et une
kate monde à aimer vraiment en même
temps pas question d'oublier leur
mission expliquer le cheminement des
produits du producteur au consommateur
surtout et qu'ils comprennent que
vraiment le circuit de qu'on a fait ce
matin qu'il va être là dans les
assiettes de refuser que ce métier
un menu élaboré pour une quarantaine de
couverts et pour la préparation elles
peuvent compter sur les conseils avisés
de la chef
notre coriande
j'ai joué le rôle du malade du manager
fait qu'ils étaient là en train de
donner des directives aux influences
euse qui ont joué le jeu et qui ont été
vraiment très présent tout au long de la
journée
[Musique]
après l'effort le réconfort place à la
dégustation et la professeurs et
personnels administratifs étaient au
rendez vous ils se sont régalés
non non j'ai suivi la chaîne est suivie
la chef mais vous pouvez vous amuser du
coup à la maison moi j'essaie de bien
mélanger les couleurs parce que quand
c'est joli ça donne un avis mais il ya
des recettes tout facile à faire à la
maison c'est rigolo quoi visiblement
c'est très bon j'avais envie de voir
parce que c'est des saveurs un peu
particulier pour les enfants il ya un
peu de gingembre il ya du poivron il ya
l'oignon rouge il ya un préjugé des a
priori sur le sur les lentilles est
illégal mais
t'as pas l'air mon nom avec la société
ça et c'est différent on a besoin qu'ils
aiment pas les lentilles c'est bien on
s'en plaint on sent pas du tout les gens
si
c'est pas une forme habituelle les
lentilles corail en plus moi j'en
consomme pas forcément très
régulièrement et puis le mélange avec
les petites pattes l'a pas mal le saumon
avec les petits légumes dessus vraiment
très goûteux mission accomplie pour les
influences euse les recettes pourraient
être intégrées au menu l'année prochaine
[Musique]